Pedro Pascal sort of jobbing actor and
now suddenly king of Television two of
the biggest shows on TV the Mandalorian
and the last of us so yeah
and are you I mean because you know
because like I say you've been in the
business for a long time are you
enjoying all this sudden attention yeah
Ariana back to your Oscar
getting lots of it like for instance
what are you
Daddy
me
[Applause]
at uh internet Daddy yeah I'm still
trying to figure it out no people are
like this daddy there's daddy
um
okay with a z i mean that sounds that's
very like silver foxy it's like never
been here about you like that I'll take
it all kind enough I guess
that's the thing is
Daddy no there's memes and stuff but
even on Twitter they're all going crazy
for it uh like I I need to stop calling
Pedro Pascal Daddy it's becoming a
problem uh
is my cool Daddy
yes I love this one down here Pedro
Pascal is a biblically gorgeous man I
want to feed him grapes I want to Fan
him with the front of a date palm Forest
Lebanon I want to find the alabaster
vial of perfume oil that one woman broke
for Jesus and comb it through his hair
yeah I'm gonna DM that person
and the last sentence is like he's
stressing me out
you're gorgeous
you don't credit yourself as Lewis
capality I don't put my name on them
just in case they're absolute Duds
returning
um yes I use pseudonyms oh yeah
pseudonyms which means fake name
that's what something I only learned
this year so yeah I used two as two
synonyms usually one in Scotland if you
go for a show you go for a Joby that's
what that's what it means some one of
them I use is Anita Joby
oh
and the other one is uh Suka fat one
I think I meant to keep them Secrets
but I think when you look at me
you you think
suck a fat one
these are these are actual credits on
songs now yeah there's one by kygo and
Dean Lewis it came out that one actually
did well so actually I've just called
them all done to know them
did very well and an easy job he wrote
that one yeah yeah I took a fat one's
yet to have any cut spot
I'm feeling I'm holding it
and so any what the guy said there that
want to shook a fat one give me a call
you like the UK you're kind of learning
to speak our language a little bit what
you're saying
yeah
you wanna you wanna do crack no I don't
that's
no come on crack you know you crack we
can have some crack
but I'm not gonna offer you crack
we're having crack yeah I think maybe if
you look good in front of it's better
good crack yeah
yeah baby steps exactly
what other phrases do you like well
um what's the uh I watch Love Island so
there's a lot of those um mug off I feel
like I'm like what are some mug like we
a mug is what you drink coffee out of
you know or like there's like a meme mug
like why are you mugging me but what
does Mug mean here I don't think it's
the same thing a mug is a face isn't it
is it well they'll be like I feel like a
mug and I'm like what how can you feel
like a ceramic cup I don't understand
me I like that one a lot I've forgotten
this I'm now looking at that are you
okay Anna Maxwell Martin
I did flag this Graham no and I'd
forgotten you did say and I'd forgot I
don't believe you forgot no but now so
you have a phobia
of something on the set
and it's not Graham and it's not Bruce
Springsteen and it's not sofas what have
you got a phobia of this is okay because
actually I can see now it's made of
plastic but I do have a favor of fruit
bowls yeah
not the bowl not the bowl the fruit the
fruit is it that they're all touching
each other I'm sorry
when did that start I just don't know
I've got a few phobias they just crop up
okay so is it the fruit or the bowl no
it's not the bowl but it's the fruit
it's the
do you eat fruit
so what'd you do for your five a day
now I don't think we're going to upset
you Anya but you have a phobia yes but I
think yours is a legitimate fear thank
you very much yeah um I am really scared
of revolving doors
oh yeah I get terrified of being cut in
half or being stuck in one um and to be
fair my first ever seen on peaky
blinders I was supposed to it was a
wanna now supposed to run in through
revolving doors grab someone take them
through the revolving doors First Take I
get stuck in there so legitimate I think
so yes and also could you have to you
have to match your speed to the speed of
the door oh God and if you're at the
airport everyone with their luggage I'm
just like I'm gonna die
the story is as you say it's kind of
that classic thing it's a sort of closed
room except it's an idea it's a closed
room I suppose a chamber piece don't you
was that what they're called yeah and a
lot of people uh I've talked about the
Benoit blanc's accent there and that was
he always going to sound like that was
that in the original script It Was
Written
um it said it was a very sort of small
piece of stage Direction which said uh
Benoit Blanc with a subtle lilting
southern accent which I
got on with that so and it's a big like
it's one of those things in your head
did you think yeah I'll do that and then
you get to presumably a read through and
you're going oh I mean I said to Ryan
the director I just said are you sure
and he went yes and they went okay
um and I just then I you know then it's
just work I I have I really struggle
with accents I can't I just can't turn
it on
um or mimic things so I have to kind of
learn it like by rote like musically and
then get it into my head and then once
it's in it's in and then I can't get rid
of it do you want to know something
really embarrassing about that period of
my life
okay
I was at a I was in New York
boreline that time probably a couple
years before 2006 let's say and a friend
of mine who's a movie producer
had this uh her kids birthday party and
her kid was turning 13 and they were
they had like you know the like Upper
East Side like well to do whatever James
organized it yeah
and they said she said Taylor would love
it if you just popped in whatever it's
it's fancy dress but do not feel the
need I was like yeah pop in a little 13
year olds I went by myself at least 13
year old kids all in really elaborate
fancy dress I got talking these two
young kids one was just like Dracula and
was just something else and I was
talking to her a bit and they went I was
wearing it was my hot face so I was
wearing like a thrillby or something and
the guy went to me I'll kill Justin
Timberlake cool
and I was like I'm I'm not I'm not I'm
not actually dressed like that I'm
actually gonna meet in the mids
and I that was genuinely the last time I
ever apart from that time
Hugh Jackman before I think we did oh we
didn't oh we did
she did once once you only remember once
oh is that all I remember yeah there's
many more times
it was at least a fortnight imagine a
corridor we did mention a corridor a
gentle strangers and he we had a great
kiss
people are very very envious we've had
another one just now so I've had two and
the night is young
keep drinking
see you guys
see but Hugh Jackman you you nearly
worked with Dame Judy oh yes well no
I wish I had worked with Dame Judy on in
anything and everything but there was a
point where my agent rang me and said
are you interested in playing Bond not
that it was an offer for Bond uh of
course I didn't know that you were
playing m at the time
um but it was one of those things where
I have since found out when I was being
asked if I was interested about eight
other actors were being asked at the
same time okay including Daniel Craig so
there we go
we're the tailoring Eddie you have
worked together we have oh wow yeah it
was a decade ago I once died in his arms
in a screen test for Les Mis
I did not know this I did not know this
yeah that there's a lot that people
don't know about this story
um basically I was I was auditioning for
two roles in Les Mis and I'd done a few
auditions and gone to New York and
whatever and I think it had been
established that I I had more of a look
of cozette but I had the range vocally
of eponine so it was established that
like I was there for a time not a long
time
but they were like you know do you want
to come to London for one last screen
test and you'll get to screen test with
Eddie Redman I'm like this seems like an
experience I want to have in my life
you're like one of my favorite actors
you're so ridiculously talented
I was like so yeah I'll go to London
um
I get there and they're like okay so we
really want to like make you look like
eponine we're gonna try to do it's the
you know she she did she wasn't like
loaded she had Brown teeth you know like
she didn't have a lot of money so a 19th
century Street yeah
it didn't floss exactly they were like
we're actually gonna paint your teeth
Brown for this and I'm like so you're
gonna do that after I meet Eddie
Redmayne right that's that's not
something you do before I get to meet
people and then you do the brown teeth
I'm like oh no it's um this is just
everybody's gonna meet you with the
brown teeth we're gonna we're gonna like
do like big circles under your eyes like
like you're near death and
I was like this this has immediately
become a nightmare for me and so then I
had you know we you were so nice but I
think when I met you I was like
it was hilarious I you know as you
walked in as a 19th century French
street urchin and and and I was not
expecting that but my overwhelming
memory of it Taylor was I had
um I'd just been to Pizza Express
beforehand and I'd had some some garlic
dough balls
I thought we were going to be singing
off with each other you know that but
they they had us also it was so weird
because Taylor was dressed fully as
ethanine and I was like in my tracksuit
and they had us on the floor like
singing Sweet Nothings into each other
and all I knew is I just had garlic
bread
I had Brown teeth
it was one of these it was like trying
to show emotions
you were weeping and I just thought it
was because of how I looked
like I have to be close to her right now
this is yeah this was not the method no
no
you're both struggling in that moment it
was a beautiful audition
[Music]